hey friends it's 2023 a brand new year
is upon us I wanted to take a moment to
kind of reflect a little bit and also to
set some intentions for the year ahead
of us because there's some big changes
that I know that I want to make in my
life and I hope there are some things on
this list that are going to be of
interest to you too Drex here from
drexfactor POI sharing with you the love
of poi spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and today
we're setting down some thoughts and
intentions for 2023 come and ride with
me before we dive in though we just want
to give a quick shout out to the Friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that I've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel Johnny Howard
Lane machinsky and Becca becklinen thank
you all so very much for your support
from my work and my mission so as I'm
recording this it is January 2nd and
um it feels really nice because normally
when we get into these months of the
winter
I'm struggling pretty bad with seasonal
depression and this is the first year
that I can remember that that has not
been the case I've been really really
really on top of doing things like like
using a therapy lamp and taking St
John's word every day to try and keep my
mind in a more positive place and the
good news is is that it's been working
and one of the great pieces of Freedom
that is coming with that is that I have
enough presence of mind not only to be
planning out some great things for the
coming year but also to really think
about the kind of year that I want to be
having so I wanted to outline 10
intentions for 2023 that I hope are
going to make me a happier person and
also bring some more joy out to the rest
of the world too so one of the most
awesome accomplishments that I had in
2022 was I became the number one POI
Channel on YouTube I overtook Nick
Woolsey and I currently stand at just
under 90 000 subscribers and in 2023 I
want to become the first POI spinner to
cross the hundred thousand subscriber
Mark Now Grant it's not like anything
comes with that aside from you know you
get a plaque from YouTube and that's
pretty cool and I really love the idea
that it says something about flow Arts
that we can have a POI channel that is a
hundred thousand Subs so
um it is going to take a little bit of
doing this coming year but I'm looking
forward to Crossing that threshold and I
hope you all do what you can to help me
out there spread the word share my
videos urge other people to subscribe we
can make this happen and in pursuit of
that honestly one of those goals that I
have been batting around for the better
part of two months now is to kind of get
back to basics with my channel a little
bit
um I've definitely experimented a lot in
the past couple years in terms of the
content that I make on this channel and
it's taken me pretty far afield from
where I started and some of those
experiments I'm really really proud of
and some of them I look back on and
think that you know I was a little bit
out of my lane and I think that going
back to really focusing on teaching
people the things that they need in
order to bring joy into their own lives
is a goal that is commendable and also
one that really should be the backbone
of this channel now that doesn't mean
that I'm going to stop doing video
essays or taking strong positions on
things inside the community but what it
does mean is that I think that the
priority once again is going to be to
help people learn this art and to make
sure that they have the opportunity to
have it bring as much joy into their
lives as it's brought into mind and
among the things that I have done to
Branch out things that I want to hold on
to 2. last year I put together my first
choreographed POI piece in something
like three or four years and it felt
really good I want to do at least two
pieces this coming year it's a very very
low threshold but at the same time
choreographing POI dance is kind of a
strange and chaotic process and I want
to both set an intention that I think is
a good one while also making sure that
I'm not stressing myself out too much
over something that is meant to be both
fun as well as fulfilling so yes that's
me kind of hedging a little bit but I
hope you understand why but I also do
want to try some new things in 2023 and
probably the biggest new thing that I
want to try is I want to Branch out into
Live Events right now I am thinking both
about doing a large scale event
something that is similar to a float or
fire Festival but with my own unique
spin on it pun intended and also perhaps
some local spin gems and trying out
different ideas to see what I can
uniquely bring to the table for both
kinds of events and whether there's an
audience for those unique things it also
doesn't hurt that 2023 is the 15-year
anniversary of me starting my YouTube
channel or I should say starting POI
videos on my YouTube channel and that is
something that I want to commemorate
that is a milestone that I definitely
want to observe and I think doing a live
event would be a good way of doing it so
keep your eyes peeled to this space
because there will be announcements I
would also like to create better
professional relationships for myself
I feel like the past couple of years
I've been doing a relatively good job of
making sure that the people that I bring
into my life as friends are people that
are super supportive and empathetic and
allowing them to be there for me in
times when it's important and I would
like to see more of that happen for
myself in my professional life as well
you know my channel is a one-man show I
do all of the writing all of the editing
all of the shooting all of the
publishing on this channel
I don't really have co-workers I don't
really have people that I get to talk
Shop with a lot and I don't have a lot
of professional relationships that
happen on a direct basis like that so I
would really love to find people both to
collaborate with as well as to work with
me and creating content on my Channel
that I have professional relationships
with in the same way that I have had my
friendships with all right now let's get
into some more personal stuff first up
and this is really silly but honestly I
kind of want to see if I can get the
splits down this year I've been taking
Fitness a lot more seriously in the past
couple years and especially since the
pandemic hit and one of those things
that I've really been wanting to work on
is my flexibility I spent most of my
adult life sitting behind a computer so
I kind of want to be able to do more
stuff with my body and flexibility and
strength training is big on the list of
things that will help with that and
honestly just being able to do the
splits is kind of bragging rights next
up doing an escape room every single
month of 2020 E3 this almost happened in
2022 it wasn't an official intention
that was set but the group of people
that I like doing this with I think
we've kind of realized that we like
doing this as a regular habit and
monthly seems like a good schedule for
that
so I'm really hoping that we can make
that happen not the least of which
because I love escape rooms and I love
solving puzzles and I love the fact that
I have friends that are as into this as
I am and we can go enjoy it together
next up I want to go visit my nieces
I've gotten to see them once a year for
the past couple years and I didn't
really get that long this past year
they're absolutely adorable the oldest
turned six today happy birthday Alana
and they're growing it fast I I want to
get metal snapshots of them as an uncle
next up I am setting an intention to go
travel and have a vacation by myself at
some point in 2023. I did do this in
2022 I went out to Utah because Salt
Lake City has two amazing natural
history museums that are right in the
same metro area and that just struck me
as being awesome so I wanted to go and
check them out and you know honestly it
was also just a great opportunity for me
to reflect and get back in touch with
myself and feel what were some things
that I had kind of been neglecting in my
personal and professional life and my
final intention for 2023 is I want to
figure out what dating and romantic
relationships look like for me at this
point in my life so I feel like it's
become more or less a meme at this point
that the dating world has become just an
absolute trash fire in the past couple
years a lot of people had a really
difficult time during the pandemic and
that has had an impact on a lot of their
personal relationships too and no
judgment here we were all struggling
there especially in the past year it's
kind of felt like a lot of the things
that I used to see as being pretty
normal in the dating world have almost
just like evaporated or the rules
somehow changed and it's been weird for
me to adjust to that not the least of
which because you know I've been going
to therapy regularly for the past four
years now and I've learned a lot about
myself in the process and there's a part
of me that wonders if what changed
wasn't the world around me but me and
that opens up a very big question of
what does it look like for me now as my
best friend Ethan refers to me as Drex
2.0 what exactly do relationships look
like for Drex 2.0 and that's what I got
for
2023. what are some of the intentions
that you all have set for 2023 I'd love
to hear them drop me a comment let me
know what your thoughts are and what
you're looking forward to this year if
you got anything out of this video
please leave a like comment share and
subscribe both to keep the conversation
going as well as to help support my
channel thank you in advance and
speaking of thank yous this video would
not be possible without the kind support
of all of these nice people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon and they along with the people
listed down in the description helps
make this video and all the videos on
this channel possible thank you one and
all for your very generous support and
if you out there watching are not
currently supporter and you would like
to become one you can do that by heading
on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up I like
making videos about flow arts and POI
spinning to help people grow and with
your support I can keep on doing that so
go check that out please and thank you
all right if you'd like to check out any
of my other flow adjacent Vlogs that I
have done over the years I will go ahead
and leave a link to a playlist of those
videos down in the description as well
as up here on screen if you are watching
on YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you might like this top
video right here based upon your past
viewing habits so maybe give that a look
as well thank you so much for watching
uh I hope that you are having a very
happy new year and I will see you with a
new video real soon
peace